من مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح ينضم
الينا مراسل الجزيره هشام زقوط هشام الوضع
لديك الاوضاع هي على حالها قصف اسرائيلي
مستمر ومتواصل في كافه انحاء قطاع غزه ل
لا سما في الدقائق وربما الساعه الماضيه
كان القصف مكثفا على جباليا شمال القطاع
حيث شنت الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه
غارات عنيفه على جباليا مخيم جباليا وبلده
جباليا كان مسرحي لهذه الغارات
الاسرائيليه المتواصله ومن المعروف ان
جباليا باتت هدفا للجيش الاسرائيلي لا سما
في ظل عمليات التوغل المستمره في هذه
المنطقه في شمال قطاع غزه القصف عنيف ومن
المدفعيه ومن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه لكن جباليا هي المسرح الاهم
لهذه الغارات الاسرائيليه تكثف الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه ما بين الفينه
والاخرى غارتها على هذه المناطق تقصف
المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه او ما تبقى من
هذه المنازل نحن نتحدث عن عده ايام بل عده
اسابيع ما زالت الحرب مستمره في تلك
المنطقه الغارات الاسرائيليه مستمره
ومتواصله عليها لا تتوقف وبالتالي لم
يتبقى لا مستشفى يعمل ولا اي مؤسسه خدمات
ولا حتى منزل يستطيع الناس اللجوء اليه
والبقاء فيه لا سما في ظل استهداف الجيش
الاسرائيلي للمنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه لا
سيما الماهوله منها في تلك المنطقه شمال
قطاع غزه يتعرض الى قصف عنيف بل حرب اباده
كما تسميها المؤسسات هنا حرب اباده بحق
الفلسطينيين الذين ما زالوا مصرين على
البقاء في تلك المناطق ايضا مدينه غزه
تعرضت الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لا
سما المناطق الشرقيه لمدينه غزه حي
الشجاعيه حي التفاح وايضا حي الدرج وحي
الدرج هو الان بات المسرح الاهم لهذه
الغارات الاسرائيليه لا سما وان الدبابات
الاسرائيليه تعمل على على ما يبدو الى
الدخول الى هذا الحي وبالتالي تقصف
المنازل المتواجده فيه هنا تحديدا ننوه
بالاخبار العاجله هشام الجيش الاسرائيلي
اعلن ان سلاح الجو استهدف 100 موقع في
جنوب قطاع غزه خلال الساعات ال4 الماضيه
ووفق ايضا مراسل الجزيره 26 فلسطينيا
استشهدوا في خانيونس وحده جنوبيه قطاع غزه
منذ مساء امس لنفصل اذا في هذه المواقع
التي تم استهدافها وعدد الشهداء
تعمل بالفعل ما الجيش الاسرائيلي عندما
يتحدث عن جنوب قطاع غزه فهو يتحدث على
المناطق التي تقع في وسط القطاع والمناطق
التي تقع في جنوب القطاع وهو يقصد جنوب
الوادي وبالتالي مناطق وسط القطاع كانت
ربما الكثافه الناريه فيها خلال ساعات فجر
هذا اليوم وساعات المساء هي الاعنف في ظل
استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي على المناطق على
مخيم البريج على مخيم المغازي ومخيم
النصيرات وهذه المناطق تعرضت الى احزمه
ناريه عشرات الغارات نفذتها الطائرات
الحربيه الاسرائيليه على البنى التحتيه
على الشوارع على المناطق المفتوحه
والزراعيه في تلك المناطق حدود قطاع غزه
حدود مخيم البريج الشرقيه ويضا الشماليه
منطقه جحر الديك كذلك منطقه المغازي
والشارع الواصل ما بين مخيم المغازي ومخيم
البريش شهدت احزمه ناريه عنيفه دمرت
العديد من هذه الطرقات وبالتالي بات
التحرك حتى للدخول الى مخيم المغازي ربما
صعبا للغايه في ظل استهداف الجيش
الاسرائيلي لمدخل هذا المخيم ايضا
الانتقال من مخيم المغازي الى مخيم البريج
بات صعبا للغايه في ظل الاستهداف المكثف
للشارع الواصل ما بين هذه المخيمات
البسيطه وا التابعه للاجئين الفلسطينيين
ايضا مخيم النصيرات كان مسرحا لغارات
عنيفه لا سما شمال هذا المخيم منطقه
المغرا منطقه ارض المفتي وايضا منطقه
مدينه الزهراء تعرضت الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه فيما تواصل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه قصف هذه المناطق
والاراضي الزراعيه فيها وبعض من هذه
القذائف تصل الى المناطق الماهوله بالسكان
وشظايا تصل الى المنازل المدنيه
الفلسطينيه ايضا مدينه خانيونس ربما القصب
بات يقترب اكثر فاكثر من وسط هذه المدينه
محيط مستشفى ناصر تعرض الى احزمه ناريه
عنيفه منطقه وسط البلد في خانيونس تعرضت
الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائ
وباتت حتى القذائف تصل الى مديات ابعد في
قلب مدينه خانيونس والمناطق الماهوله
بالسكان وكان هناك ايضا قصف عنيف على
المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس وهي التي تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف من الطائرات ومن المدفعيه
ونقل من جراء هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه في
جنوب قطاع غزه لا سما في رفح وفي خانيونس
نحو 26 شهيدا وهذا يرتبط هشام بالعمليات
البريه
هناك بالفعل العمليات البريه مازالت مستم
ممره ومتواصله في اكثر من محور وفي اكثر
من محافظه محافظه خانيونس المناطق الشرقيه
فيها التوغل بات فيها منذ عده اسابيع ونحن
نتحدث عن منطقه عبسان والقرار وخزاعه وبن
سيلا وهذه المناطق تحاصرها الدبابات
الاسرائيليه بل وتقطع الشارع الرئيسي شارع
صلاح الدين وتمنع الوصول حتى الى خانيونس
والى رفح من مناطق وسط القطاع الى من خلال
قطعها لهذا الشارع ايضا هي تحاصر هذه
المناطق الشرقيه لخان يونس من الجهه
الشرقيه ومن الجهه الغربيه وبالتالي تمنع
وصول سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع
المدني الى المناطق التي تستهدفها في هذه
المنطقه بالتالي القصف عنيف في الاحياء
الشرقيه لخان يونس في ظل استمرار التوغل
الاسرائيلي في هذا المحور وعمليات الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما زالت مستمره بالاضافه الى
الاشتباكات والمقاومه الضاريه في تلك
المناطق لا سما في هذه المناطق الشرقيه
المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعلن ما بين الفينه
والاخ اخرى عن عمليات تنفذها في هذه
المناطق ايضا دير البلح وسط القطاع ايضا
تشهد المناطق الشرقيه فيها عمليات توغل
كذلك كذلك منطقه جحر الديك هناك عمليات
توغل بسيطه حي الشجاعيه ما زال محاصرا
وعملي التوغل مازالت مستمره والاقتراب
اكثر فاكثر من حي الدرج حيث المناطق
الماهوله بالسكان والتي لجا اليها الناس
في ظل استمرار القصف الاسرائيلي للاحياء
الشرقيه جباليا وشمال القطاع ما زال ايضا
التوغل اسرائيلي مستمره من مستشفى شهداء
الاقصى في دير البلح مراسل الجزيره هشام
زقوط شكرا جزيلا لك